vegas will bounce back very soon from
the pandemic
that is what several businesses and
local politicians stated during the
vegas chamber preview las vegas virtual
event
where experts forecast our local economy
christian khazar is joining us live in
studio with a sneak peek
about what was discussed christian well
brian great news for las vegas many
local business leaders say the city
will bounce back before the end of 2021
because we are
an event based community and we have so
many things to look forward to
now derek stevens owner of the new circa
las vegas said the city
has something for everyone from watch
parties to sporting events and concerts
even the restaurant industry because we
are a great culinary town
now the lvcva president and ceo shared
research about how
the city has taken steps to protect
visitors they say tourists will remain
health conscious for an extended period
of time
throughout the entire legislative
session the vegas chamber will
absolutely be looking out for you
every single day the vegas chamber will
be vigilant
in defeating any policies that would
make it harder for you to operate a
business
and to keep people employed well
everyone agreed that the pandemic has
forced us to move toward a more digital
platform like teleworking
online shopping and ordering food but
once the virus is under control
innovation will be
our next challenge now we can't forget
that we also have so much to look
forward to
with the raiders and the golden knights
win or lose they generate traffic
which leads to more hotel room bookings
and dinner reservations
it's only a matter of time until we see
that boost christian casadas 8 news now